[Music]
get out of my bar freak
in the world of superhero movies post
batman and robin implosion spider-man
showed they could still be fun and
batman begins demonstrated gravitas
we were supposed to protect them
where were you when your own people
needed you
hiding meanwhile the x-men prove that
the ensemble superhero movie could work
just take off the yellow spandex add
some millennium era leather and retain
the franchise's outsider allegories i
promised myself i'd find a cure you have
no idea what i'd give to feel
normal
the relentless x2 x-men united brought
true action to the series before hitting
the skids with the last stand and x-men
origins wolverine since then the x-men
franchise is spread out in myriad ways
with highlights including time travel
fourth wall breaking and an emotional
goodbye to everyone's favorite wolverine
before the mcu introduces their version
of mutants we're ranking every x-men
film by tomato meter
[Music]
number 13 dark phoenix
the x-men face their most formidable and
powerful foe when one of their own jean
grey starts to spiral out of control
during a rescue mission in outer space
jean is nearly killed when she's hit by
a mysterious cosmic force once she
returns home this force not only makes
her infinitely more powerful but far
more unstable the x-men must now band
together to save her soul and battle
aliens that want to use grey's new
abilities to rule the galaxy starring
sophie turner james mcavoy jessica
chastain and directed by simon kinberg
critics say dark phoenix ends an era of
the x-men franchise by taking a second
stab at adapting a classic comics arc
with deeply disappointing results
no no no no no no no please don't die
[Music]
number 12 the new mutants
five teenage mutants undergo treatments
at a secret institution that will cure
them of their dangerous powers invited
by dr cecilia reyes to share their
stories their memories soon turn into
terrifying realities as they start to
question why they're being held and
who's trying to destroy them starring
maisie williams anna taylor joy charlie
heaton and directed by josh boone
critics say rendering a list of
potentially explosive ingredients mostly
inert the new mutants is a franchise
spin-off that's less than the sum of its
super-powered parts
come on iliana you gotta do something
seriously
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
where the hell did you go
there's a special place
that was so hot
number 11 x-men origins wolverine
seeking solace from his dark past logan
seems to have found love and contentment
with kayla silver fox logan's peaceful
existence is shattered when victor creed
brutally murders kayla logan's search
for revenge propels him into the weapon
x program where he undergoes a painful
procedure to bond his bones with
adamantium making him virtually
indestructible and more than a match for
victor starring hugh jackman leave
schreiber will i am and directed by
gavin hood critics say though hugh
jackman gives his all he can't help
x-men origins wolverine overcome a
cliche written script and familiar
narrative
two years i run in that hell when i
never
oh
shiny
tell me something jimmy
you even know how to kill me
i'm gonna cut your damn head off
see if that works
so old man
you're gonna die for what you did
number 10 x-men apocalypse
worshipped as a god since the dawn of
civilization the immortal apocalypse
becomes the first and most powerful
mutant awakening after thousands of
years he recruits the disheartened
magneto and other mutants to create a
new world order as the fate of the earth
hangs in the balance professor x and
raven lead a team of young x-men to stop
their seemingly invincible nemesis from
destroying mankind starring james mcavoy
michael fassbender and oscar isaac
critics say overloaded action and a
cliched villain take the focus away from
otherwise strong performers and resonant
themes making x-men apocalypse a
middling chapter of the venerable
superhero franchise
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
unleash your power
let god
[Music]
[Music]
number nine x-men the last stand
the discovery of a cure for mutations
leads to a turning point for mutants
they may now choose to give up their
powers and become fully human or retain
their uniqueness and remain isolated war
looms between the followers of charles
xavier who preaches tolerance and those
of magneto who advocates survival of the
fittest starring hugh jackman patrick
stewart and famke jensen critics say
x-men the last stand provides plenty of
mutant action for fans of the franchise
even if it does so at the expense of its
predecessor's deeper character moments
that's it
[Music]
[Music]
number eight the wolverine
lured to a japan he hasn't seen since
world war ii century-old mutant
wolverine finds himself in a shadowy
realm of yakuza and samurai wolverine is
pushed to his physical and emotional
brink when he's forced to go on the run
with a powerful industrialist daughter
and is confronted for the first time
with the prospect of death as he
struggles to rediscover the hero within
himself he must grapple with powerful
foes and the ghosts of his own haunted
past starring hugh jackman hiroyuki
sonata rila fukushima and directed by
james mangold critics say although its
final act succumbs to the usual
cartoonish antics the wolverine is one
superhero movie that manages to stay
true to the comics while keeping casual
viewers entertained
oh
[Music]
oh
number seven x-men in a world filled
with hate and prejudice mutants are
feared by those who cannot accept their
differences led by professor xavier the
x-men fight to protect a world that
fears them but they are locked in a
battle with former colleague and friend
magneto who believes humans and mutants
should never coexist starring hugh
jackman patrick stewart and ian mckellen
critics say faithful to the comics and
filled with action x-men brings a
crowded slate of classic marvel
characters to the screen with a talented
ensemble cast and surprisingly sharp
narrative focus
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
number six deadpool 2.
wisecracking mercenary deadpool meets
russell an angry teenage mutant who
lives at an orphanage when russell
becomes a target of cable deadpool
realizes that he'll need some help
saving the boy from such a superior
enemy he soon joins forces with bedlim
shatterstar domino and other powerful
mutants to protect young russell from
cable and his advanced weaponry starring
ryan reynolds josh brolin zazzy beats
and directed by david leach critics say
though it threatens to buckle under the
weight of its meta gags deadpool 2 is a
gory gleeful lampoon of the superhero
genre buoyed by ryan reynolds's
undeniable charm
give me your best shot one-eyed willy
oh
those bullets are like super fast
here we go
[Music]
[Music]
number five x2 x-men united
striker a villainous former army
commander holds the key to wolverine's
past and the future of the x-men this
threat reignites the call for a mutant
registration act striker starts a
full-out assault on professor xavier's
mansion in school and after escaping his
plastic cell magneto proposes a
partnership with xavier and the x-men to
combat this new formidable enemy they
both have in common starring patrick
stewart hugh jackman and halle berry
critics say tightly scripted solidly
acted and impressively ambitious x2
x-men united is bigger and better than
its predecessor and a benchmark for
comic sequels in general
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
roof
[Music]
number four deadpool
wade wilson is a former special forces
operative who now works as a mercenary
his world comes crashing down when evil
scientist ajax tortures disfigures and
transforms him into deadpool the rogue
experiment leaves deadpool with
accelerated healing powers and a twisted
sense of humor with help from mutant
allies colossus and negasonic teenage
warhead deadpool uses his new skills to
hunt down the man who nearly destroyed
his life starring ryan reynolds marina
baccarin ed screen and directed by tim
miller critics say fast funny and
gleefully profane the fourth wall
busting deadpool subverts superhero film
formula with wildly entertaining and
decidedly non-family friendly results
rich
have you seen this man
[Applause]
[Music]
yanking
ugh
i've never said this but don't swallow
number three x-men first class in the
early 1960s during the height of the
cold war a mutant named charles xavier
meets a fellow mutant named eric lyncher
despite their vastly different
backgrounds charles grew up with a
wealthy family while eric lost his
parents at auschwitz the two become
close friends as the world teeters on
the brink of a nuclear war charles and
eric with other mutants joined forces to
save humanity however a situation soon
tears the friends apart starring michael
fassbender james mcavoy jennifer
lawrence and directed by matthew vaughn
critics say with a strong script stylish
direction and powerful performances from
its well-rounded cast x-men first class
is a welcome return to form for the
franchise
i still can't locate sure he's down
there we need to find him now
yes we do
maxie's got a location on shore
you ready for this
let's find out
[Music]
number two x-men days of future past
convinced that mutants pose a threat to
humanity dr boulevard trask develops the
sentinels enormous robotic weapons that
can detect a mutant gene and zero in on
that person in the 21st century the
sentinels have evolved into highly
efficient killing machines with mutants
now facing extinction wolverine
volunteers to go back in time and rally
the x-men of the past to help change a
pivotal moment in history and thereby
save their future starring hugh jackman
james mcavoy and michael fassbender
critics say x-men days of future pass
combines the best elements of the series
to produce a satisfyingly fast-paced
outing that ranks among the franchise's
finest installments
[Music]
foreign
so
and finally number one logan
in the near future a weary logan cares
for an ailing professor x at a remote
outpost on the mexican border his plan
to hide from the outside world gets
upended when he meets a young mutant who
is very much like him logan must now
protect the girl and battle the dark
forces that want to capture her starring
hugh jackman patrick stewart daphne
keane and directed by james mangold
critics say hugh jackman makes the most
of his final outing as wolverine with a
gritty nuanced performance in a violent
but surprisingly thoughtful superhero
action film that defies genre
conventions
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
get a point get off points
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love and until
next time i am your host naz perez and
we'll see you back here for more top
tens on the rotten tomatoes countdown
you